it does not look good
what's happening Daniel Daniel the
Daniel is it
is it benefit now do you all like are
y'all about it or is it like you're over
we've been working together for 12 13
years now
um and when we started we thought it was
a funny name to like oh we're both named
Daniel let's call ourselves Daniels
that's you know we'll never have to live
with that for the next decade
and now yeah it's it's on every movie
poster and uh I don't yeah I don't I
feel bad for all the other Daniels in
the world okay we wanted to be a
monopoly whenever we need one
in the little mad congratulations
leading nominations like do you really
just walk in here like yeah this is like
we we did that absolutely yeah it's
totally I've totally absorbed it if if
full-on doesn't I forget it is true like
I'll be talking to like a family member
and they'll bring it up and I'll be like
that wait oh that's real now yeah
exactly yeah yeah especially walking
around today uh in this environment
you're just surrounded by all these
incredible filmmakers that you know many
people we grew up on many people that we
Roger deacons is outside yeah right
there you're sitting in that listener
right now he was sitting in that chair
feels like he was in it except for you
but really it is it is surreal um we've
been saying this whole time that you
know the fact that we even got to make
the movie is was enough that was all we
cared for because even that felt
impossible
um but yesterday I was talking to
Michelle and she was so just happy and
light in a way that I haven't seen her
in a while and she says the fact that we
got this far is already a win let's just
have fun and I was like okay if Michelle
yo says I can have fun now I'm gonna
I'll take that to her dangerous yeah
exactly I mean she is really having fun
I mean I saw you guys on the night of
the Critics Choice like I mean you guys
really look like y'all are just enjoying
like the time that was the night where I
think everybody enjoyed the time
our table was special we had a lot of
our crew that night because the Critics
Choice like nominated a a lot of like
crew departments and uh it was that was
extra special because it's so rare that
they're a part of all this you know and
and the fact that we got to like sit
with I was sitting next to my VFX
supervisor and like he was in the
background of every time they would cut
to Bob Odenkirk it would be like Zach
behind him yeah and I was like this is
very fun
oh man that's so great for you guys
along this journey what has been the
most special part I think the thing that
has really sustained us this year is the
fact that we get to go to these q and
A's and you know every time we're a
little exhausted I'm like I can't
believe to talk in front of another
crowd but by the end of it it's really
reinvigorating because we have these
wonderful audience members who have
fallen in love with the movie some of
them have told us they've seen it 13
times you know that's more times than I
think I've seen it
um
well the finished cut yes for sure the
finished rough Cuts oh my God and they
they they tell us their story and they
tell us who they brought to the movie
and how it's changed their life in
different ways and it's the kind of
thing that you only dream of as a
filmmaker that you could have this kind
of impact on even one person's life and
so it's that being able to go to all
these screenings and have different
stories repeating very similar
narratives is incredibly moving and also
I do think it's it's putting a lot of um
pressure like a lot of good pressure on
our shoulders just to remind ourselves
that like filmmaking is very powerful it
can be used for good and we are in a
very unique position now where um yeah
we don't want to waste this opportunity
yeah and also that the movie is bigger
than us yeah you know that like that
this recognition like validates their
stories yes in a way that like is is a
nice reminder you know yeah whether it's
Asian American families immigrant
families uh people who are you know not
neurotypical in their mind ADHD
depression anxiety like to get spanked
like to get spanked on all the stories
people also just like you know Hong Kong
action nerds you know the whole spectrum
of people who have come to us and said
thank you for the movie for different
reasons we tried to put make a movie
about everything and we we didn't
succeed because that's impossible but we
got a couple things
America will be talking about his first
president
Mandy let's keep it real yeah making
history as the third ever female
cinematographer yes I will say making
him look good on screen was hard work
right no not very hard and and you know
what he's such a great collaborator and
generous with the camera being you know
coming from 50 foot away straight into
his face and being very calm and not
even flinching you know it was just for
such a dream to be honest we said we
danced with Austin on stage with the
camera which was it's such a dream talk
about the look of it so I'm definitely
going to stalk with you Catherine and
then again just the incredible look of
Elvis well thank you and that is because
I'm part of an incredible team and it
starts with
the boss
um no one ever calls me the boss
Gracie does
the crazy does
Ada who puts an emphasis on the visual
story telling aspect of filmmaking so
what's great about being one of his
collaborators is that you get focus and
care and respect and time to do your
best work and encouragement to do your
best work so
baz also provides an atmosphere where he
pushes you to do the things that you
find the scariest the things that are
beyond your comfort zone beyond what
you're thinking
think you're capable of and then if you
fail there's no shame which I think
really makes you a better artist in the
long term
so
yes it's the great joy of working and
working with the team who are sitting
here and our extended team who
you know back in Australia is this
feeling of satisfaction that as a group
we've managed to fulfill the ambition of
telling this big Universal story that
encompasses really difficult historical
periods in history and American history
very ugly periods
and at the same time deals with subjects
that are still really potent today the
idea of Art and commerce of the
exploitation of the artist
and the complication the complicated
relationships that artists have with
their managers
and in general selling and
um you know and the human
coming together in a very uncomfortable
mix yeah but as I I do have to say to
you sir of everything that you've done I
feel like little bits of your filmmaking
are part of this film like almost like
you kind of had to make all the films
you had to make to make Elvis does it
feel that way for you there is no doubt
a lot of all the films I've made the
Journey of making this film and the film
itself and then the life after the film
there will be no Road like this again
it's it's a Once in a Lifetime
experience and everything I've ever done
has been put into it but also just to
begin with I mean I mean we started with
a fire and then a flood and then a
pandemic and you know then Austin
refusing to leave when the pandemic came
when the film was open saying I'm not
leaving I'm not leaving the role of a
light and it just kept working and then
Tom coming back then we shoot we get the
film done and then this can we get older
audiences in can we get younger
audiences in then they come then
everyone just lives on and on and it
grows and of course the very personal
Journey we've gone on with the Presley
family which is just you know
um unimaginable and there's been so much
Beauty and so much emotion
um yes it's indelible I'll never forget
this particular one what has been the
most sort of like uncanny valley bizarre
part of this whole season for each one
of you and I'll give you all a quick hit
like you know I mean by the very nature
of it it's uncanny and bizarreish you
never want to disrespect it because you
know like I like saying it's at a
wedding you're the bride but it never
stops but then again you could have been
left at the altar you know
I'll take the long wedding anytime so
that's a great thing I call it the
chicken dinner circuit but I have to
tell you with great respect
um but there is no level of zanious
zaniness that won't come with it and yet
there's it's a lot of great things but
the strange thing about it is you you
dress up you go out you're celebrated
you you see whether but in the end of
the day you go like I'm dressing up I'm
celebrating I'm seeing other people
because
it's like a whirlwind but also just to
be with with us as a group or being
nominated is just really the icing on
the cake and that we're all celebrating
together and you know we we made an
amazing film and and being recognized
for it and I'm just really proud we have
a problem
I received an
evening
there's no reason to get caught up in
any intrigue
I'm worried now that the film has been
out in the world
are you a marveled at how many different
ways people approach it and what they
take as they see it because it really
has become this other thing to so many
different people in different ways yes
yeah no certainly um
I mean we were hoping that people would
engage with it and have very strong
opinions about their own interpretation
of it but the manner in which the
conversation has um Amplified is not
something we would have ever imagined I
mean it's fairly extraordinary you know
it's like every week There's an opinion
piece on this film and that's not
something that you would ever
contemplate both you and Kate as you
guys have been talking and Nina and
everyone Natalie that I'm involved in
the film did you both have the same
approach to the character from those
first early conversations or did she or
is she one of those people when you
first started talking to her about it
where she maybe had a different
interpretation no I think we both had a
very good picture of who Lydia tar was
um and I am I think we had the same aim
in terms of trying to make something
that allowed room for the viewer it is
that strange thing because you do have
to let it go completely because that's
why you made it for good or for ill you
know and even though you want the
conversation to be loud and noisy and
diverse and dynamic at the same time
there's that part of you that feels
really protective over the thing that
you made and I think that's that way for
you know all filmmakers yeah what do you
think about that aspect the fandom of
Lydia tar because there's people like
like treating her real like it's almost
like uh Miss Pitman like the The Legend
of Pitman yeah yeah no I know I mean
that's a testament to Kate panchett her
art you know when we were off in
Scotland my editor Monica Willie and I
we would walk every morning and we you
know we did this for months seven day
weeks and really within the first two
weeks we no longer referred to her as
Kate it was it was Lydia tar and it felt
as if we were you know cutting a
documentary and then it was a question
which is you know how fair should we be
to this person who was a very real
person to us or not and that's a
testament to her art and and and her her
magnificent you know ability as a
performer I think the best thing about
it is the music and the fact that Hilder
has become this like great Lydia tar
Avatar because of how much she created
what lady did talk about working with
her for not only helping you create who
Lydia tar was in the sense of
underscoring her actions on screen but
also really fleshing out the character a
little bit with Kate well I mean Hilder
and I started our work together in
Berlin as soon as I got on the ground
actually she's the first person that I
started to work with and we worked
together for 14 months so that that's
not very typical when you work with a
composer especially for a movie where
most of the music is canonical work and
was already in the script and hilder's
not underscoring she's trying to
disappear it's the most modest sort of
approach for an artist
and yet it's so deeply embedded in the
material you know there's there's 40
minutes of of
hilder's
compositions that you feel in the mix
but hopefully you don't hear and that
was a conscious effort on both of our
part because if you have a character
that's making music on screen it would
be absurd to underscore their life so
that was a really interesting way to
work with her um
but also because she asked incredible
questions you know she would say you
know what what is her internal Rhythm
how does she move you know you don't
normally have conversations like that
with people you know and and say what do
you mean she said well what what kind of
music were you listening to when you're
writing the script I was like okay well
this is one piece it's 120 beats a
minute she's like okay well then her
she's 120 beats a minute so she brought
in a whole group of players to create
music that you will never hear on screen
just to put into Kate's ear so that when
she's walking it's always this is her
gay always or if you watch if you watch
the Sophie coward who plays a young
cellist Olga mckina 60.
and and it's not something that the
audience should ever be aware of but it
does something to you and in that way
very much the way Wagner used to score
he used to underscore which is it was
very very pointillistic way to work and
it's just incredible uh experience to
work with an artist like that here's to
the Future
here's to getting back up
and here's the coming home with Empire
of light in particular collaborations
with Sam what were your first
conversations with them because I think
a lot of people going into it didn't
know how much it spoke to his own
history
yeah obviously I knew it was um it was
very personal to him I mean we we
started talking about like we had other
projects you know we just had long
conversations about the script and the
Arc of the script and you know what
maybe didn't need to be there things
like that you know and then gradually
kind of talked started talking about the
look of it how we should shoot it so you
know it's the with any film it's kind of
like a bit of an evolving conversation
you have over time one of the things I
loved about Empire of light is there's a
great moment with Toby Jones where he
really speaks to the beauty of movie
Motion Pictures into the cameras into
the lights and the magic of the
projection room is that the reason why
you decided to sort of do the
Photography book is it that you sort of
looking at your work with moving Motion
Pictures and sort of having that same
sort of like this is why we do it or was
it really you know just another book
yeah byways yeah
um no I mean uh my whole life I on and
off I've taken still photographs but I
just take photographs of things that
kind of
interests me things that catch my eye so
you know during the pandemic my wife
James and I thought well it's about good
time see if we can get a book published
you know I've taken more photographs
since then I wish I'd delayed it because
I'd like to maybe I'll do another book
but I just take photo of nothing to do
with my film world really yeah no no
they're just very personal
photographs I take when I just go
walking exploring you know the journey
in your introduction you talked about
this was part of your early days even
before you were working on film sets I
guess back in Devon like talk about this
journey with with you in photography and
again and I guess you know those first
early days working with it well I
started off I wanted to be a painter
like everybody does if they don't know
what they want to do really and I went
to our College avoiding work and I
discovered photography I met uh they're
a photographer called Roger Maine a
street photographer who was one of the
first street photographers actually in
the 50s in London and he inspired me to
start going out and taking still
photographs and that then that just
developed I was taking very naturalistic
photographs so then I thought when the
national Film School in England opened I
thought well maybe I should think about
documentaries you know making
documentaries so my photographs could
talk basically and you know so one thing
led to another and here I am